hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar best practices five steps to
live cell imaging i am michelle action
of leopards and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lovers and
brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about our
sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor in the
presentation to do so simply type the
mississippi ask a question box and click
send all questions will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
after the presentation is over if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit I now present today's speaker
Auggie Gollum PhD Rd scientist of
protein and cell analysis at Thermo
Fisher Scientific for complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
on D you may now begin your presentation
okay
well it seems that it's about time that
we got started with today's webinar now
I'd like to first thank all of you for
joining us today in attending this
webinar on live cell imaging my name is
Ogie Golub I'm an R&D scientist with
thermo Fisher Scientific I'm located in
the Eugene Oregon facility which was
formerly the molecular probes campus
where we work on developing many of the
commonly used dyes and fluorescent
conjugates that are used in fluorescence
microscopy and today's webinar will be
solely focused on live cell imaging
using fluorescence and that specific
breakdown of the topic will be presented
in a manner we'll recover what we refer
to as the five steps to live cell
imaging so the five steps to lifestyle
imaging will essentially serve as kind
of an outline for the remainder of this
talk and the steps are outlined here in
this in this slide we're essentially the
first two steps are largely aimed at
essentially determining whether live
cell imaging is really necessary for the
type of experimental question that one
is trying to investigate and then of
course culturing those cells in
preparation for a live cell imaging
experiment and so with those two steps
being something that's pretty commonly
performed in in most labs we'll go ahead
and focus most of the content and
today's webinar on the on the last three
steps which is really where our
expertise from the product development
comes in with determining the optimal
types of labels for live cell
experiments as well as how to optimize
your labeling and imaging conditions so
that you can get quality data and then
last but not least we will also touch
base on how to go about actually
performing live cell imaging without any
detrimental effects because as many of
you are probably familiar with
to live cell imaging it can be quite a
bit more challenging than imaging fixed
dead cells so what are some of the main
advantages of the live cell imaging over
fixed cell imaging so if we if we start
at the very first step of kind of the
the planning phase what we're trying to
build a foundation for our entire
experiment we should really sit down at
first and and determine what advantages
we stand to gain from doing moving into
live cell imaging versus kind of the
traditional fixed type of analysis so of
course one of the main advantages can be
illustrated with these panels here on
the right or if we look at the
traditional fixed cell specimen on the
bottom right we might be able to
investigate some type of biological
event happening over time by taking
snapshots at different time points
whereas if we perform lifestyle imaging
we can actually observe these processing
as they happen in real time and so this
allows us to track interactions between
cells and within cells and their
compartments and so if this of course it
grants a whole new dimension for
analysis and much better physiological
relevance now some of the considerations
to keep in mind of course is that the
labeling approach is for live cells is
can be quite drastically different then
the approach is that one would take four
fixed cell preparations and then from an
imaging standpoint as I mentioned even
in the previous slide it can be quite a
bit more challenging to actually capture
this data because the cells are moving
and you're subjecting them to light over
continuous time time periods and they
need to be in a proper environment and
incubator so there's quite a few things
to think about here and we'll talk about
these in subsequent slides so if we go
back to these five steps we can move
into step number two where we really are
now committed to a live cell imaging
experiment and so we need to start off
with a nice healthy cell culture because
as with really any biological experiment
a successful experiment starts with a
nice healthy cell culture so we need to
learn how to properly grow and maintain
our cells in their optimal growth
conditions I won't spend too much time
on this topic because again I think that
this is something that's very commonly
found in and in most labs you know we
have pretty standard practices for
culturing and growing the cell types
that were commonly working with some of
the more common considerations to think
about when culturing your cells are of
course the plates and the dishes that
are being used any particular additives
or media supplements that might be
required for your specific cell type and
then of course you need to have the
proper environmental control for these
cells to grow in in an incubator but
before you can even really start to
perform any types of experiments and
assays and even for routine passages of
cells it is quite essential during the
culturing phase to have a proper cell
count of your cultures as you're
progressing from one passage to the next
and as your even sub passages for an
experiment and I mean again for a
successful experiment it really does
need to begin with an accurate cell
count and so cell counting is relatively
straightforward to perform a release
that seems that way on the face of it
until you start to really kind of get
into these higher density cultures and
being able to track my ability along
with total cell count is where
instruments and benchtop cell counter
such as the countess to FL are really
very very powerful companion devices
that really enabled you to not only get
more accurate results but more
reproducible results from one time to to
the next so this is a type of instrument
that of course allows you to not only
generate a total cell count but also
viability cell count in order to assess
how many of the cells that you have in
your population are actually viable and
usable for downstream
applications going back to our outline
of steps we will now move into really
kind of the meat of the rest of this
talk which as I mentioned and the
introduction will really be focused on
steps three four and five which are you
know labeling optimizing and imaging in
live cell cultures so if we start with
kind of a high-level overview of the
different labeling methods that are
available to us generally speaking they
fall into these three pretty distinct
categories where we have perhaps the
most commonly used approach here on the
left which is using antibodies typically
this is of course done with primary
antibody that recognizes your antigen of
interest inside or on the on the outside
of the cell and then that primary
antibody is followed up with a secondary
antibody that's conjugated to floor
force most traditionally and then those
floor fours are what we are able to
detect unfortunately this approach is
generally not compatible with live cell
imaging since antibodies tend to be
rather large and bulky and not celled
permeable in the rare instance that you
have a cell surface marker you may be
able to visualize it using an antibody
but most intracellular labels are not
compatible with antibody labeling so
this is where we now start to rely on
different types of approaches one of
them of course is genetically encoded
approach so these are the traditional
fluorescent protein types of labels so
GFP RFP and really all the rest of the
fluorescent protein family and these are
of course require live cells in order to
be expressed and folded up properly and
become fluorescent so this is very much
a lifestyle compatible workflow and then
really the bread and butter of the
campus that I work at the former
molecular probes campus are of course
small molecule fluorescent conjugates
where we rely on organic dyes in
to either deliver the dyes themselves
directly to a compartment or conjugate
the dyes to another molecule in order to
give it specificity and not all of these
are lifestyle compatible but many are so
we'll talk about some different examples
of lifestyle compatible fluorescent
molecules in the next set of slides but
first we'll cover various approaches
towards genetically encoded labeling
methods and one of these methods that we
have developed over the years is called
back man
and back man essentially stands for
insect baculovirus with a million
promoter and as that name implies what
that tells us is that this is a
technology that takes advantage of an
insect a virus a baculovirus and what
we've done is we've substituted the
insect promoter with the million CMV
promoter in order to facilitate the
expression in mammalian cells so on the
right is a table that highlights some of
the commonly available back man reagents
that are ready to be used and that this
is really one of the key advantages to
this approach is that because this is a
prepackaged virus it is not only easy to
use but it is ready to be expressed in
cells without really any molecular
cloning needed by the end user and as
you can see on the table on the right
there's a pretty broad selection of both
GFP and rfp fused targeting domains that
either enable you to visualize different
organelles and compartments within a
cell as well as different cytoskeletal
structures so one of the key
considerations for using vacuum
technology is is essentially getting the
most optimal transduction efficiency so
the reagent is relatively easy to use
where essentially comes prepackaged as a
concentrated viral titer that you
essentially dilute onto your cells and
incubate over overnight and so then when
you show up the following morning you
have cells that are expressing your
fluorescent proteins that are now ready
for lifes
Imaging generally speaking the highest
transduction efficiency happens while
the cells are still and in their log
phase growth and so you want to
transduce before they're fully confluent
generally speaking at a confluency of
about 70 percent or less and then
different cell types respond to the
virus in different levels and they may
require a different multiplicity of
infection from one cell type to the next
so this is one of the key parameters
that really needs to be determined for
your specific cell type regardless of
the virus that's being used is you need
to determine what's called the mo I or
the multiplicity of infection and that's
done relatively easily you essentially
need to establish a titration of the
viral particle on your cell and
generally speaking this range is
somewhere between about 5 and 100 viral
particles per per cell and so using a
very simple equation that's highlighted
there on the bottom you can determine
the volume of reagents that you need for
your labeling now besides genetically
encoded approaches as I mentioned
another commonly taken approach is using
small molecule organic dyes and so this
is what I would like to actually spend
the vast majority of the rest of this
talk focused on it is different types of
fluorescent labels and molecules and
different approaches that we can take
towards optimizing their their use so
here we have an example of a live cell
on a u2 s cells specifically that's
labeled with three different tracker
dyes so many of our trackers are indeed
intended for live cell imaging and so
here what we have is an example of a
cell that's labeled with three different
live Sun compatible trackers we have a
tubulin tracker deep red my tour tracker
green and a lie so tracker blue so what
we now see is that we're of course able
to not only label these specific
structures but we're able to multiplex
using multiple multiple dyes in order to
visualize different structures at
once and one of the really key
advantages to this approach over
genetically encoded approaches is is
yours is the speed with which you are
able to achieve labeling this is
generally accomplished within anywhere
from 15 minutes to an hour depending on
the on the reagent and its mechanism of
loading and another really great
advantage that can often be overlooked
is that because the these small
molecules are incubated on top of the
cells in the media what you end up with
is a very uniform staining across your
entire population that can be one of the
significant drawbacks to genetic
approaches is that you will have cells
that have taken up multiple or variable
levels of virus and are therefore
variably expressing compared to one
another so you can have quite drastic
levels of labeling an expression where
as with the small molecule fluorescent
labels the labeling tends to be very
uniform because all cells are incubated
with the same concentration and for the
same amount of time some of the
considerations to think about just like
with everything else there's of course
drawbacks to this approach as well and
one of the key drawbacks is that you can
get non specificity that that can result
from excessive labeling is essentially
from using too high of a concentration
high concentrations will also
potentially affect the physiology of
your cells and potentially induce
prolonged cell cycle and maybe even
cytotoxicity at very high concentrations
but when you get those concentrations
and conditions right
they of course enable you to perform
live cell imaging that can be tracked
over over time either on the scale of
hours or even days so I'd like to start
with really just a very high-level
consideration of using small molecule
fluorescent labels and that's
concentration this is something that we
spend a lot of time optimizing during
the development of these of these types
of conjugates and so this is an example
of that tubulin tracker deep red that I
showed in the pre
a slide and this is something that I
worked on personally over the past
couple of years so during the
development of this particular label
what we found is that if we tried to
perform these long time lapse
experiments with cells incubated with
about one micromolar of the reagent what
we see is that after about a couple days
and at the end of 48 hours in this in
this case we see that the cell cycle
essentially completely slows down and at
the end of this time-lapse T cells die
completely whereas if we cut that
concentration down tenfold to about
point 1 micromolar we can now see that
at this 48-hour time point the cells are
not only completely alive but they're
able to go all the way out to 72 hours
and during this entire time we'll have
star able to divide proliferate
microtubules are still exhibiting their
normal dynamic behavior and everything
is physiologically unperturbed in this
event and the only difference
essentially between these two
experimental conditions is the
concentration that's used so it's a very
important consideration when using these
types of labels for long term time-lapse
imaging is to make sure that you do not
excessively label because the dye itself
can of course in or interfere and
perturbed with the natural physiological
mechanisms of your of your cell type so
that's really just one of the key
parameters that needs to be optimized
and again oftentimes this is something
that we will spend a lot of time
performing the optimization on on the on
the front end but of course we're not
really able to do this with every single
cell type out there so it is something
that sometimes needs to be performed on
a cell type-specific basis but we'll at
least provide general guidelines on
concentrations and fold delusions on
where to start so we'll move into step
number four then and really talk about
some of the other parameters that that
can be thought about for optimization
during live cell imaging
one of the really key parameters to
think about when investigating live
cells is is of course this this question
an idea of are we perturbing the system
and are we are we causing some type of
toxicity to our cell line just by the
sheer nature of labeling them with the
fluorescent molecule so because these
experiments can be quite time-consuming
to generate and to really fine-tune it's
quite important to really investigate
this the state of the cell health upon
either you know your your labeling or
some type of treatment that you're doing
and this can be done using various
indicators that we refer to as hell
health indicators and so these are
typically reagents that span the self
health continuum as we refer to it as
where we have completely healthy cells
and the reporter will enable you to get
an assessment of how healthy or if those
cells are indeed healthy all the way out
to a completely dead population and
everything in between so what we have
here on the right is an example of a
couple different reagents that can
actually be multiplexed to give you a
combined picture of of cell health in
particular mitochondrial health by
looking at the mitochondrial health
using a small molecule label called TMR
m which loads based on mitochondrial
membrane potential and this is being
multiplexed with reactive oxygen species
detect they're called cell rocks and
green so what we have here is an example
of u2s cells that have been treated with
a drug called Menand ion which displaces
cytochrome c from from the electron
transport chain and so with this now
results in is a drastic increase in
reactive oxygen species and so if we
start this time-lapse will see that
these red healthy mitochondria start to
depolarize and therefore the t mrm
signal leaks out and we now see that as
the cytochrome C is being displaced then
we get this uptick in reactive oxygens
from the men and ion taking effect we
see that the positive
signal from the salt rocks the reactive
oxygen species sensor starts to come on
so this is a really elegant and
effective way to investigate the health
of your population by using a combined
approach one that gives you a readout
for healthy cells and one that gives you
a readout of toxic cells now these types
of experiments as I mentioned can be
rather time-consuming to not only set up
but also acquire and can involve quite a
bit of setup and optimization and and
troubleshooting so a really easy and
elegant approach towards speeding some
of the some of this work up on the front
end is to use a slightly simpler
approach where we're not necessarily
doing time-lapse imaging and setting up
these continuous multi hour overnight
potentially time lapses and trying over
and over again as we can we can actually
use the countess once again but instead
of for just simply counting the cells
like we did at the front end for a
culturing and passages
the countess FL or the countess - I fell
specifically is actually compatible with
two fluorescent light cubes from our
evos microscopes and so what this now
allows you to do is investigate
fluorescence or a positive fluorescent
signal using a benchtop cell counter so
if we go back to that same example from
the previous slide of investigating
mitochondrial health using TMR m and
Solrock screen if we pull samples from
these various time points and simply
trips an eyes the cells so that we can
load them into the countess
we can now assess whether the treatment
is working and if the reagents are
indeed giving us giving us an enough
signal in the proper response by
assessing the fluorescence in the
countess - FL and so on on the bottom we
see a representative image of one of
those data points where we see that
we're at this transition between the
Texas red T mrm signal going down and
the gfp positive cell rocks and green
signal coming on um so it's it's really
just another tool that one should
consider when really kind of starting to
set up a new set of experiments this can
be rather powerful and quite
quite valuable in terms of time can type
savings so in this next set of slides
what I'd like to talk about a bit are
different approaches that one can take
to improve the loading and retention of
these fluorescent labels that we've been
talking about because often times it can
be a bit of a challenge to get some of
these labels into living cells and then
once they're in there they tend to want
to disperse and essentially leak out
over time and so there are a couple
different reagents and approaches that
we can that we can utilize in order to
improve both of these steps so well the
advantages here are of course that it
enables us to get higher signal with
lower background over over time but of
course some considerations that we have
to take or that these approaches may not
be compatible in all cell types and the
fact that we're going to be adding
additional components to these
experiments also mean that potentially
we may induce some cytotoxic effects so
we'll talk about that here a little bit
in the following slides
the first approach I'd like to talk
about is a method for improving the
loading of different fluorescent labels
and so this can be done with different
compounds that we typically refer to as
surfactants and one of them is called
pleure onic f 1:27 in the previous slide
you saw an illustration referring to a
product called power load and power load
is essentially a combination of these
different products that has been
formulated for loading of AM esters here
what we're using as a single player onic
F 127 that we have found to be very
effective for loading our green
turbulent tracker so we'll be using this
tubulin tracker example throughout much
of this this talk and as I mentioned
before the new reagent that we worked on
recently is this deep red version of
tubulin tracker so what we could
actually see here is that if we look at
our original tubulin tracker the green
on the bottom on the bottom left we have
a fluorescent image that has matched of
exposure and contrast to the image on
the on the right and what we see is that
if we just think of it with the tubulin
tracker by itself we don't get very
effective loading at all the signal is
actually quite dim and is really barely
above background and that can be
reflected in the quantification there on
the right but if we co incubate and load
with piranha F 127 we see a drastic
increase in the loading of this
particular of this particularly 'l now
on the other hand if we employ the same
approach with our new table and tracker
deep red we'll see that the molecule by
itself is actually quite effective at
loading without blur on ik and that by
the addition of blur on ik we actually
are causing a detrimental effect on the
amount of signal that we have to work
with so this is what I was referring to
in the previous slide where these
approaches aren't necessarily a
universal solution and may indeed be
detrimental but in the cases where we
found them to be effective they gret and
greatly and drastically improve the
loading of these fluorescent dyes now of
course another issue that you often
encounter when doing live cell imaging
especially over long periods of time is
that even though the label might get
loaded and is successfully internalized
into the cells as you often are required
to perform what's called a washout step
so that means you have to exchange the
media that contains all the unbound and
non loaded floor four so that you can
decrease the background that you're
working with and so with this of course
means is that as soon as you exchange
the media you know are going to have
exchange of the molecule from inside the
cell wanting to leak out and and go
outside so that's what we can
essentially see here is that the
retention of these labels will start to
suffer after a couple of hours and so
this is again another example of
turbulent tracker and this one is just
looking at tubulin tracker deep red and
if we use a efflux pump inhibitor called
probenecid what we see is that we can
actually greatly improve their
mention of these small molecules over
longer periods of time by enabling them
to stay it retained inside the cells by
blocking those a flux pumps so on the
top we have a representative image from
the first time point of these cells
being loaded and then they're being
incubated and imaged over time I'm in
complete media but without any prevents
at present and what we see after about
two hours is that the signal not only
decreased but the background greatly
increased as in indicating that the
probe is leaking out of the cells and
into the media and contributing to this
background background fluorescence now
if we perform the same type of labeling
but incubate these cells with prevent
acid present in complete media what we
see is that we can image over this time
course of about two hours with really
very minimal loss in signal and very
minimal increase in background and you
can see this being present on the
right-hand quantification as well
consideration with this as with many
things that we've talked about so far
including you know the labels themselves
you want to make sure that you're not
using them at too high of a
concentration the same holds true for
probenecid you want to make sure that
you're not using it at too high of a
concentration or for too long otherwise
you will induce cytotoxicity from that
that blockage of the efflux pumps over
extended incubation times last but not
least once we've loaded the cells and
have incubated them was something like
prevent acid to prevent the leaking out
of the label we're now of course ready
to start imaging our cells on live cell
microscope and so at this point we're
going to start subjecting the cells to a
fair amount of light in order to get
some signal out of these fluorophores
and as well many of you are I'm sure
familiar light is not only damaging to
the cells themselves but it's also
damaging to the floor floors that were
imaging so with many fixed cell
protocols and imaging approaches we will
often use a mounting medium which
prevents photo bleaching so would
typically refer to these as
anteye fades and what we have developed
in the past is an anti fade that's
compatible with live cells as well with
the idea being that we're also trying to
preserve not only the signal from fixed
cell preparations but also all the
signals a signal that we get in live
cell preparation so here we have a
couple representative images of cells
that are being that are being imaged at
a hundred 20 independent consecutive
exposures with and without the prolong
live anti-fade live cell imaging reagent
and on the top we have the cells that
are being protected with prolonged live
and on the bottom we have cells that are
untreated you can see the drastic
difference in the remaining signal with
and without the prolong live ant evade
and the consideration to think about
with this approach though is just
because you're able to protect the
signal from photo bleaching that that
doesn't mean that you should continue to
put light into the system because even
though you have signal remaining from
your floor force high illumination may
still induce photo toxicity we'll move
on now into a different category instead
of looking at how to label and retain
and preserve signal what we'd actually
what I'd like to spend a little bit of
time talking about is the other side of
imaging which is background right so
everything that we do in imaging is
really aimed at enhancing our signal
while lowering the background in order
to have the best contrast on not only
for you know visually appealing images
but for something that we can actually
quantify in segments and get some type
of valuable information out of so we'd
have various sources of background that
we need to deal with we of course have
background from the instrument and the
camera or whatever detector that we're
using which is something that we rarely
have any control over but we do have
control over some of these other sources
such as from the reagent itself as I
briefly alluded to a couple slides ago
when we typically do these small
molecule labeling experiments we will
often need to remove and
wash out the label at the end of that
incubation to remove any nonspecifically
bound probe and so with this now of
course leads to is the leaking out of
that probe out of the cells but it does
remove much of that extracellular
background that will be found in the
medium the samples that we work with of
course can also be Auto fluorescent
specifically and in the shorter
wavelengths and the greens and in the
blues and then the media that many of us
use for culturing cells will have Auto
fluorescent components that are very
useful indicators of pH but are quite
detrimental in terms of image quality so
this is probably one of the simplest
steps that we can take towards reducing
background is actually in the the
culturing media by simply removing those
Auto fluorescent components from the
media we can greatly improve the
contrast by reducing the background from
the media contribution and this can be
accomplished by using a specific
formulation of DMM that's called flora
bright VMM which is essentially the
media but without the phenol red in it
for indicating pH so what we can see is
a couple representative images of
regular DMM with all the all the
components including the phenol red and
then on the bottom we have a
representative image of cells that are
being imaged in this optically clear
flora bright DMM and then on the right
is a quantification of this of signal to
background in either PBS which of course
is positive control here that is also
optically clear that is essentially
comparable to the floor bright DMM
signal to background whereas DMM with
phenol red has relatively low signal to
background compared to these two these
two approaches so this is pretty simple
thing to do and they can really greatly
improve the signal to background by
eliminating background from the media
Contribution now another approach that
one can take specifically in live cells
is by use of a background suppressor so
this is a with a different reagent
that's called backdrop background
suppressor and the way that this works
essentially is that it's a reagent that
quenches any signal outside of living
cells and so it's it's a dye that's a
general quencher of fluorescence but it
is not sold permeable so what that means
is that when you incubate cells with the
labels such as tubulin Tracker green or
tubulin Tracker deep red again going
back to that same example of these two
molecules that we've been talking about
for loading and retention what we see is
that if we don't perform a washout step
and we've before and when we take an
image with tubulin tracker in green in
particular we see that every single
pixel in this frame is fully saturated
and then the same is essentially true
for DIC tubulin tracked deep red but to
a slightly lesser extent now if we start
to take a live movie of this acquisition
and we flow in the backdrop suppressor
what we see is that as soon as the
backdrop is applied and incubated with
these cells it successfully quenches all
signal outside of these cells and so
again the idea here is that and to
general quencher of fluorescence which
is not able to cross the cell membrane
and so the quench is all the unbound dye
that's in the media while leaving your
intracellular signal intact and so this
works very well with many in green and
red fluorescent conjugates and then as
you can see here to a certain extent
it's also quite effective with deep red
floor floors but again this is specific
to living cells only in the event that
the cell membrane is in any way
compromised whether that be due to cell
death or due to some type of fix or
permeability type of workflow the
quencher will get inside the cells and
it will quench all signal equally inside
and out so it is only for live cell
imaging so that was a pretty brief
overview of some of the different
labeling methods as well
as some of the different optimization
methods and so then in the in the last
bit of this talk I'd like to spend a
little bit of time talking about
different approaches in consideration
when it comes to actually imaging live
cells on a microscope so first and
foremost much like with step number two
where we needed to culture the cells in
preparation for a live cell experiment
when we're performing a live cell
experiment especially over longer
periods of time one of the key
considerations to keep in mind is that
we need to keep the cells in their
natural healthy environment so this
means that we need to incubate them
generally speaking that this is done at
37 degrees Celsius with about 5% co2 20
percent o2 and then we try to keep the
humidity as as high as possible and the
idea behind keeping the humidity high is
that you prevent evaporation of your
media over time as it sits on the
microscope the higher you can keep the
humidity the less evaporation you'll
have and the longer you can image so
here we have an example of 48 hour time
lapse taking images every two frames on
whatever Evos M 7000 microscopes and so
this vivo 7000 is equipped with an
on-stage incubator that you can see
there to the left of the microscope and
so that essentially provides a small
incubator on the stage of the microscope
that enables you to not only modulate
the temperature that the cells are in
but also the environmental condition in
terms of gas content and humidity but if
we keep things generally normal and
constant well we can now see is that we
can monitor cells over time and we can
see these cells move and divide and
proliferate over the course of this
time-lapse now in order to generate that
type of data it is important to of
course keep your image in focus and that
can actually be pretty challenging when
it comes to imaging live cells because
live cells are still alive and therefore
they're moving and they're not only
moving and moving laterally your x and y
but there's also slight shifts in their
Z position based on small adjustments
and small shifts and in the temperature
as well as just the potentially even the
stage of your microscope depending on
the type of instrument that you're using
and so this is where we of course need
to use some type of auto focusing
routine in order to keep your image and
focus and most commonly this is
performed by using the fluorescent
signal itself as we'll run an algorithm
that will take a small Z stack through
through a volume and then that Z stack
will interpret where the signal is is
essentially the highest in order to keep
that signal in focus but what this
results in is a whole lot of extra light
going into into the system and go in and
exposing to your cells and so this can
actually result in a fair amount of
photo toxicity and this isn't really
something that's only a problem for auto
focusing it's a general consideration
for lifestyle imaging to keep in mind
how much light and how frequently you're
sampling because if you're sampling
frequency is too high or using too much
light you'll essentially end up with a
lot of cell death and so we can see is
an example of that here on the left is
if we perform autofocus with high
illumination settings will see that at
about the 20 hour time point most of
these cells stop to you know stop moving
and indeed start to completely die by
the end whereas the same time lapse is
being run on the right with lower auto
focus illumination conditions and we can
see that these cells are much happier
they're able to continue proliferating
and growing much like what we saw and in
that first first example on the previous
slide so some considerations in general
to keep in mind to prevent photo
toxicity is to use the longest
wavelengths of dyes that you have
available the longer the wavelength the
lower the energy of the light that's
going into exciting them and therefore
the lower the photo toxicity will be and
if your instrument is equipped with a
laser nearer for a laser auto focusing
auto focusing laser then I would highly
recommend that you utilize that in place
of fluorescence based auto focus and
then from a setting standpoint you
a relatively low illumination power with
higher exposures and gain will compare
to what you would typically do with
fixed cell imaging this may result in a
slightly grainy er image but it will
allow yourselves to survive these longer
time courses and then generally speaking
your sampling frequencies shouldn't be
too aggressive the more frequently you
image the more light you're putting on
your cells and then the more stress
they'll be from that light so as a
general rule of thumb we tend to start
with sampling frequencies of about
twenty to thirty minutes especially if
using floor floors that are excited and
the violet and/or green channels last
but not least I would also like to touch
base on different types of microscope so
what I would I showed in the last couple
slides was an example of one of our wide
field
Evos systems but many users of course
have the need for confocal microscopes
as well and one of the main advantages
of a confocal microscope is of course
their ability to take optical sections
in 3d specimens but they also provide
not only high resolution images due to
generally high quality optics but also
very high signal to background by
minimizing much of that background by
simply eliminating that light from ever
reaching the detector so we talked about
a couple different examples of
suppressing background using wide field
microscopes such as using the background
suppressor and taking out the phenol red
out of the media on the confocal
microscope itself will actually greatly
aid in a suppression of background as
well by simply imaging only a very thin
a thin volume within the Z dimension
which will essentially reject much of
that auto fluorescent or background
fluorescent light from the media so many
times an experiment that requires a wash
and with a wide field system can be
performed in an OLE wash type of
workflow using a confocal system so this
is going to be example of
of using that tubulin tracker deep-red
once again but in this case we're
actually taking images without
performing a wash step using a confocal
so you can see right off the bat that
the image quality is actually quite
quite superior in terms of signal to
background where even though we're
leaving the label on the cells at the
entire time we don't have that that
drastic auto or sorry background
fluorescence outside the cells from
unloaded dye I mean we're not using any
any suppressor or anything of this sort
here either
now one of the other advantages to using
these types of scopes as their general
sensitivity tends to be much higher so
this also means that you can sample and
much higher intervals in frequencies so
now instead of taking twenty images
every twenty minutes we're actually able
to take an image every five minutes on
and these are primary hippocampal
neurons which are relatively sensitive
cell type compared to the heal is that
we were imaging previously and we can
see that we're able to image these every
five minutes all the way out to about 72
hours without really any induction of
cell health or cell toxicity or
detachment from the substrate and this
is again
also duly in part due to the fact that
the tubulin tracker deep-red is excited
by a deep red 638 nanometer laser so
this longer wavelength combined with the
higher sensitivity of the detector
enables us to not only sample over
longer periods of time while keeping the
label on board the entire time for free
exchange inside and outside the cells
but it also enables us to have much much
higher sampling frequency without
causing any cytotoxicity some
considerations to think about before
moving from a wide field to confocal is
that it may not always be necessary
oftentimes the confocal instruments and
shared facilities will have a cost
associated with them and that cost may
not you know be necessary for the
experiment that you're that you're
trying to perform and then even though
we have
higher sensitivity detectors on many
confocal systems we also tend to have
much higher intensity laser illumination
so this can lead to a greater risk of
photo toxicity due to higher intensity
laser illumination so this is where it's
generally good practice to use the
highest PMT gain or camera gain
depending on the type of tech detector
that you have using the highest gain
setting that doesn't degrade image
quality while losing the lowest amount
of laser power possible in order to
minimize any cytotoxic effects so in
summary these are the five steps that we
have talked about today and are kind of
the general five steps that one can take
when it comes to performing live cell
imaging the first step as we talked
about of course is to determine if live
cell imaging is necessary for your
experimental studies it can be quite a
bit more challenging and time-consuming
to perform a live cell experiment versus
a fixed type approach and so it is
important to really spend some time
thinking about if it's as if it's
necessary and then also planning out how
to execute that experiment the second
step is to culture cells and start with
with a nice healthy culture that is not
overcome fluent and that is growing in
optimized growth conditions both in
terms of environmental conditions and
culturing media and then really this is
where kind of the rubber usually hits
the road is is that as a step 3 when it
comes to labeling and optimizing and
imaging this is where it's really
important to start paying attention to
things like concentration its spectral
overlap and really kind of spending some
time again planning your labeling
strategy and choosing the reagents that
not only minimize spectral spillover
effects but also cytotoxic effects and
so that's where it's important to really
spend some time in step number form to
optimize these conditions and methods in
your particular experimental condition
because these these things will vary
from one cell type to the next and so
these first four steps can be pretty
time-consuming all on their own
and then the last
is you know generally one that can be
overlooked from time to time which is
the imaging but it can actually be also
relatively challenging to perform the
imaging itself because there are
multiple parameters to think of when it
comes to using fluorescence in live
cells and one of them as we've talked
about pretty extensively in the previous
slides is not only the effect of
cytotoxicity from your label on the
photo toxicity from the act of imaging
the cells too frequently and with too
much illumination so that concludes this
particular five steps webinar for more
information about our webinars and
similar types of types of content please
feel free to visit our website for
various various five steps tutorials and
more information and with that I would
like to thank all of you once again for
not only your attendance today but also
for any questions that may arise and so
with that I'd be happy to take questions
thank you thank you algae for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab herbs and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
laberd's will alert you via email when
this webinar is available to replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have this
today's event until next time goodbye